hey guys Ryan writes right here and
Jerry's dairying over Jerry yes he is so
today we're gonna talk about the
Incredible Hulk thumbnail okay so the
Incredible Hulk little spoiler talk here
we're not gonna cover all the things
that you know everyone else has covered
before we don't know what we're gonna
cover actually I like this movie I don't
love this movie though it is definitely
not one of Marvel strongest yeah I mean
it's it's stronger arguably than
angley's hope it's one of the marble
movies I haven't really returned to and
I haven't really felt a desire to return
to to watch more than one time yeah I
could see that because I'm doing the
whole phase 1 and phase 2 movie marathon
and I honestly kind of wanted to just
skip it I was watching this and I'm like
this is enough interesting as the other
ones but there's things about it that I
really do like I'm like Stan Lee's cameo
they actually gave him a pivotal role
because what happens is he's working in
the factory his blood drops of one of
the bottles and that bottle goes to Stan
Lee
and they're like it's gamma poisoning we
know where Bruce Banner is now he's in
wherever they're making those bottles so
that was a cool cameo cuz normally Stan
Lee just shows up and like some stupid
one-liner I guess I like everyone
ordered spoof I liked his performance
there's nothing groundbreaking about his
performance or like really special like
I can see why people will not have a
problem with him being recast for the
Avengers because there's nothing really
special about Bruce Banner in that movie
well yeah there's a weird thing and
maybe it's just because I've heard the
news since cuz I know they had a lot of
trouble behind the scenes like with him
really wanting Final Cut and like him
being really you know like the sort of
driving force behind this movie and
that's sort of what I remember is like
remember a lot of Edward Norton kind of
be in broody and [ __ ] the action
sequences I do enjoy like that I gotta
give it credit for that because there's
the action sequence at the beginning
with the rooftop chase and then he turns
into the Hulk and that was really cool
because they kept the Hulk in the
shadows the whole time so it's like you
set him up as this like terrifying
monster and so he's just thrashing [ __ ]
around and you just see one shot of him
where Tim Roth is like shooting at him
and you see the Hulk's face for the
first time that was cool I liked the
fight scene
where he's hanging out with Aerosmith's
daughter yeah he's saying I would live
Tyler and then the army shows up and
then he turns into the hope that was a
cool fight I'm like the whole supersonic
wave thing that happens of course the
final fight scene was really cool with
abomination like I gotta give that I
gotta give a lot of credit that final
fight scene because I've seen this movie
three times now every time I get to that
I'm like okay yeah this that made the
movie much more worth it that climactic
fight is really interesting cuz you know
you think of movies like transformers or
you're watching like Giants fight each
other and it's just visuals
that's essentially what this is but the
way it was captured with the
cinematography it looked real and like
to this day I'm like it looks fairly
real for the most part but and that's
also not a movie that's like overly
bloated with all that kind of yeah you
know like they actually have like a
chase going on you know sort of a cat
and mouse between him and Tim Roth
throughout the movie and I mean it's so
much of a Hulk movie is about him trying
to not Hulk out yeah you know whereas
like a Transformers movie is just like I
just make more robots punch each other
for a while it does make an interesting
comparison for the two because Tim Roth
is all about wanting more more more of
this [ __ ] and Bruce banners like yeah so
when they come together to fight just
realizing this alright now when they
come together to the fight it is pretty
powerful because it's a clash of
ideologies yeah because it's two very
different if they're different monsters
with the same gamma thing but they're
fighting for different causes and at the
same time you got to watch the build-up
happen you know he's not hulking out for
most of the film he's Bruce Banner
through most of it and I just liked also
that while he's Bruce Banner he
confronts the idea that he wears
stretchy pants cuz yes that keep his
pants up yeah yeah he that comes up like
three times and with abomination they're
like abomination effects he was scary
you know you look like something
Resident Evil yeah right yeah and
there's some brutal stuff in that my
tyrant
I do have a question though because he's
named the Hulk through like those news
reports it's like some type of whole
coup you know one of those things and I
don't think Bruce Banner caught bad
newsroom
and then when he's fighting as the Hulk
in the end he goes Hulk smash I'm like
wait why did you just call himself oh
yeah that was always a problem for me
with this movie is and and and
throughout it wasn't until the Avengers
where I feel like somebody actually
properly handled Hulk smash for the now
it's like you can have hope in a cartoon
or in a comic book home smash because
like you've established a tone that
supports that when he said that in this
movie I was completely taken out of it
for a second yeah I mean that moment
seemed a little shoehorn in for me yeah
and then the Avengers like Captain
America says Hulk it's like that's your
things like Hulk smash like that was
[ __ ] great and this movie just kind
of sounded silly yeah you know it did it
really did but overall that last fight
scene was cool I did like the way to end
it actually would hold me in like oh
[ __ ] I gotta go yeah cuz he does look
really bummed out I remember thinking
that when the helicopter show up after
that long-ass fight and he's just like
like really depressed yeah you know and
you see at the adding get it til I
didn't get it to like the third time
watching it but I see now in the finale
whatever Norden when he's like
meditating he's intentionally channeling
it so he's learning how to activate the
Hulk in him which truly which
transitioned into the Avengers with Mark
Ruffalo's when he's like I think he
knows how to turn into it when he needs
to I sort of find myself wondering if
Hulk will ever get another standalone
movie and I kind of wish that someone
can figure that out especially now that
we have Mark Ruffalo because I liked him
where Norton's performance in this but I
feel like Mark Ruffalo he is just is he
is Joyce he has the one yeah and it's
like everyone's a good choice but he
also really wanted to do so it's like
you know you did a good job but you're
trying to do this a bit too hard words
like Mark Ruffalo just feels like yeah
it's the guys like yeah that's the guy
who's a scientist and a Giant Hulk
monster absolutely absolutely he has
this sincerity down to a whole new level
William Hurt in this movie though was
yeah I thought he was so over the top he
seemed like he was aware
was in a comic book movie no but there
but but that seemed to be kind of a
thing with a lot of the supporting
characters I think I mean I really like
Tim Blake Nelson but he even seemed kind
of like oh like I'm a devious comic book
guy what it seemed like he was trying to
do was honor the show actually I got Lou
Ferrigno in that cameo and that was a
good cameo to like I like how they
handle their cameos and I know Lou
Ferrigno did the voice of the Hulk again
in that movie this movie certainly has
its moments but William Hertz
over-the-top Tim Roth you know I like
this movie for the most part even though
it seems like I'm bagging on the film
right now the make up of him when he
gets like buffer I just didn't like I
was like this doesn't look real when he
has like a six-pack and like all these
muscles I'm like and I love how his body
just gets perfect but his face stays
exactly the same age like a 20 year old
body a same face very cool or not a
sting but they put a scene in there
didn't they were where Tony Stark finds
a bit of bar or whatever yeah and they
showed that all over the trailers yeah
Tony Stark shows up that was good that
was a good Avengers tease because you
actually instead of getting Nick Fury
you get Iron Man himself to make it
appear yeah overall from beginning
middle and end like there it has its
moments of good heart I thought the
movie in terms of characters started
becoming more interesting like 40
minutes in when Liv Tyler and Edward
Norton start like having scenes together
you know like I wasn't exactly 100%
drawn to the romance but there are some
fun moments like they're about to have
sex but then his heart rate gets too
high so he's afraid he's gonna turn into
the Hulk yeah I were just done er anyway
don't know hope thrashed you over give
that poor girl apart yeah well you know
what it would be the best orgasm death
ever
yeah you never know no I do know you
never know I don't think it's worth
finding out that dick would destroy her
ah
just imagine them no I don't want to and
I don't I don't want to imagine it now
nope it'd be like Mortal Kombat X you
just put it in her and then she just
splits apart in half and then you see
her guts just fall all over the place
whole quiz fairy tale there were a
couple of characters in this movie that
they set up a tower
gonna get their appearances again the
scientist guy I liked him he was like a
cartoon character
the one who was help mr. blue who is
helping out ed Norton but was he Tim
Blake Nelson yeah like oh brother yeah
yeah he was good I liked unliked his
level of energy I liked his philosophy
towards it how he was fascinated with
the power
I forgot the character he was supposed
to be calm but they were hinting at it
at one point blood perfectly drops onto
his wound his brain starts to get bigger
there was that and then Liv Tyler had a
boyfriend at the time I love my Liv
Tyler had like no contemplation as to
like feeling morally bad this fugitive
ex-boyfriend of mine took off he comes
back and I'm just gonna completely
forget about my current boyfriend he's a
therapist and he was he's supposed to
turn into a villain two down the road
one thing I want from the Hulk movies
this is what I liked about Mark
Ruffalo's performance was you can tell
Mark Ruffalo had a temper problem that
he was always fighting against I think
the Hulk's mentality is something that
could be really interesting to explore
it's a guy who has anger issues and when
he gets angry he becomes a monster you
know it's a good like allegory for
people with anger problems it's kind of
like a werewolf story exactly yeah it
could be a very interesting tale like
but I don't like about the Hulk films
that we've got in there more about like
the adventure and the military coming in
and stuff yeah well that's the problem
is like this is a character has like a
serious emotional problem that is the
root of his power
you know that's then complicated by
radioactive yeah her radiation that
doesn't necessarily lend itself to being
a big loud action movie as much as does
sort of a personal struggle story it
would be a I think you'd be more
interesting if they added more personal
struggle into the mix if you have that
aspect of it it makes Bruce Banner that
much more relatable it just makes him
seem more human at the end of the day
instead of watching the movie going once
he get Hulk out again yeah I like how
the Avengers played with it where it was
like you don't want him to turn into the
Hulk ash it will go bad if he does
yeah that's the take out with our prefer
if they did a whole movies you can make
a really dark emotional tale out of the
hole and that's what I want if they if
they end up doing another reboot or if
they end up doing a solo movie the Mark
Ruffalo I hope I hope that's what we get
yeah
sassy somehow I still am sort of
wondering if that would ever happen but
if they do I I hope Marvel can continue
their sort of approach of making each of
these different series a different kind
of movie and to really draw from that
because they really sort of broken away
from making your standards superhero
comic book movie I think that was the
problem with this Hulk film was that
they were paying too much tribute and
following along the lines of the 1970
show you know rather than just going
let's just make it our own thing right
now yeah this was still early cuz the
Iron Man is still a comic book movie
mm-hmm cuz that's the first thing
they're trying dude
then you get into Thor and you get into
Captain America and those start to
become like Thor's a fantasy movie as
well as the superhero movie in Captain
America is a period piece war movie or
the second one is you know an espionage
movie so it's like now they're a bit
more confident they can make they can
cross genres together and I hope to see
that happen to the whole yeah now that
it's a thing
so bottom line I don't love the
Incredible Hulk but I like it enough to
repeat view it when I'm doing these puns
yeah anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can sub it to the real
rejects and you could check Gerry's
playlist reasons to Gerry and you can
follow Facebook Instagram and Twitter
comm slash the real rejects mmm see I
cut out those words what I didn't say
subscribe oh yeah and say check it out
and I said follow Facebook okay so
follow Facebook Instagram and Twitter
yeah you don't have to follow us on
there before we end this video I do
think that there should be a sex scene
with a Hulk and a human woman or
she-hulk and the hole that'll be it
that's where they have sex in New York
City and they destroy it all in New York
that would be the post-credits